[Music]
halsy opens up like never before in a
new interview with Rolling Stone and
we're breaking down her five most candid
revelations
[Music]
[Applause]
starting with this the badet love singer
who's been diagnosed with bipolar
disorder reveals that she secretly
checked herself into a psychiatric
hospital twice since becoming famous
I've said to my manager hey I'm not
going to do anything bad right now but
I'm getting to the point where I'm
scared that I might so I need to go
figure this out the 24 year olds also
shared her thoughts on sexual abuse
opening up about her own experience and
why she doesn't really talk about it
quote then I'm not grammy-nominated pop
star then I'm a rape survivor uh-uh
no absolutely not I have worked way too
[ __ ] hard to be quantified or
categorized by something like that but
it wasn't all heavy while Halsey may be
an international superstar that doesn't
stop her from doing her own grocery
shopping she explained quote I'm 24 15
years old I'm a grown-ass woman I can't
be this being codependent helpless thing
who has someone who does everything for
them cuz I'll kill myself I will
literally go crazy mostly everyone just
tells me surround yourself with your
friends good people and don't take
yourself too seriously and in terms of
her upcoming third album Halsey says
it's quote the first I've ever written
manic while discussing her bipolar
disorder she admits that she knows the
feeling won't last forever and someday
she'll be struggling with hopeless
thoughts quote I know I'm just going to
get depressed and be boring again soon
and last but not least Halsey revealed
that while she may be known for her
music she's also a whiz in the kitchen
quote have you ever been to the New York
restaurant Carbone every time I eat
their spicy rigatoni I'm like I can make
this way better I think we need to see a
cook-off anyway I love how open and
honest Halsey was in this interview and
of course we'll be here to share all the
breaking Halsey news so be sure to keep
it locked right here on ET until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]